you're facing a an epic battle that
isn't even just for you know Western
Civilization we are literally talking
about the future of the human race and
whether there will be one so if that
doesn't get you
to stand up
and face the enemy irrespective of what
it is you know if the enemy is all
powerful and it's going to destroy those
of us who stand up then the point is
what that will do is it will destroy
everyone else shortly thereafter so
you're not saving yourself that mucho
you might as well face the thing and the
lesson of frankly the woke Revolution
and uh covid and much else is that
actually you might be surprised that you
end up on the winning team and that
feels pretty
good all right friend Einstein last we
did this we were in London at the ark
conference about a month or five weeks
ago or so and we agreed to do it again
so here we are and you're you're in a
suit this time I've never seen you this
professional I don't think I've ever
seen you wearing a tie are you going
into a new line of work what's going on
here well Dave we are at War and I think
it's incumbent on us to dress
appropriately we are at War at some
level I think sort of across the board
we're at war with our Institution
with we're at war with our sens making
apparatus we seem to be politically at
war with everybody I guess why don't we
just start there what what is on your
mind the most at this very moment well I
am concerned that we are in a kind of
war that none of us have seen previously
and that this is a war that actually
must be won that were we to fail to win
the war to I don't even think defending
the West is possible at this point but
to rekindle it from what remains if we
lose that war then where we're going I
think is
unsurvivable for uh the species really
and you know I wish I wish there was
more Nuance about it but that is that is
how it looks to me all right so let's do
the black pill first so what is the
black pill where is it that you see us
going that if we don't rekindle we are
going to end up at what does that place
look like to you um as we may have
talked about in London the there are
really two bases on which you could run
a civilization one of them involves uh
just simply narrowly trying to advance
your genes into the future at the
expense of other people's genes and that
looks like lineages battling with each
other sometimes it's genocide sometimes
it's War sometimes it's more cryptic
than that but it really is uh it is
about what we have come to call Race and
then there is what that's sort of the
battles of the old days in some respects
yes that was that was all there was for
a very long time and in fact that is the
The Crucible that shaped our species and
it happens that in more recent history
we've discovered a better way and that
involves putting aside lineage level
concerns and collaborating with people
who are in a position to be good
collaborators really that idea has to
take over the whole world that is
Humanity's future if we're to have one
and unfortunately
the I think what has happened is that
what allowed a civilization based on
reciprocity to
thrive
was uh a commitment to the consent of
the Govern and the problem is for the
rent seeking Elites that have that have
hoarded so much power the idea of the
consent of the government is very
frightening because it can take power
away from them at any moment and Ward it
to somebody else and you know that is
indeed a frightening Prospect but
they've conspired against it and what is
going to happen is that that beautiful
system which you know we never completed
but the system that was being erected in
the west uh when it collapses it's going
to return us to that lineage against
lineage conflict um because that is the
more fundamental more stable State and
unfortunately if the world returns to
that mode with present level of
technology and weaponry we aren't going
to just get through it and a hundred
years from now emerge to ReDiscover what
we once knew I really don't think we'll
be here all right now everyone watching
this knows that I'm not going to let you
just blackpill us the whole time and I
know that that's not your intention and
actually your life's work is to to not
do that at all but just to give the
devil is due and do as much of what you
just discussed as we can so would you
say it's something like we've had you
know 250 plus years of the Enlightenment
that got us past much of the tribal
stuff and now we're we're just at the
end of it does does this feel inevitable
where we're at at the moment especially
if you look at what's happened you know
since October 7th where we're now seeing
a new version of tribalism burst forth
does it seem like the obvious end of
Enlightenment
liberalism unfortunately something that
guys like you and I tried to defend very
hard before it was cool I guess right
and while there was still more
opportunity it's now later unfortunately
in that uh in that history but I think
it was not inevitable but in order to
avoid it we needed to recognize what we
had and not delude ourselves about how
complete the job had been in other words
recognizing that we had effectively
discovered the the broad structure that
we needed to live by and had never fully
achieved it right obviously the founders
of the American experiment
simultaneously understood that nobody
needed to be given advantage over
anybody else or it was essential that
they not have advantage over anybody
else at the same time they preserved
slavery so it was never perfect it was
at best a prototype but we had to
recognize what that prototype implied
about what kind of world we could have
and then we needed to defend it with
everything we had we needed to defend it
and we needed to I don't even want to
say complete it because that that
implies that you're going to get there
and there's no there there approach it
right you're going to get to a place
where the gap between the system you
have and the system that you're trying
that you're shooting for is so small
it's it's not worth messing anything up
over what do you think the closest we've
ever got to that was like to I always
say on the show now if we could just
reverse it to 1995 were probably
probably pretty good well yes and no I
think
1995 is not a bad estimate of the
closest we got right and just as a proxy
for it the degree to which one one's
race for lack of a better term mattered
was probably at a low EB at that point
yeah it didn't matter at the level of
zero it mattered right and certain races
mattered more than others but everybody
understood all of the decent people
understood that it was desirable to have
a world in which everybody had access to
the market nobody was barred because of
where they came from and we have now
lost touch with that obviously we've
we've rce the idea that nothing matters
more and of course that is going to
produce uh a Revival of all of the
ancient rivalries and a bunch of new
ones and it just doesn't look survivable
and what's more I think if you could
just simply teleport everybody for a
couple of days into the future that they
are toying with delivering us all too
they would recognize instantly that the
loss that they were that they were
contemplating was just Unthinkable what
if you could teleport the other way so
what if we could teleport to 1995
assuming it's a roughly does it's not
the exact year but ballparking that
things were better what would you tell
the people of 1995 you're supposed to do
in the face of this because that's what
I keep coming back to a bunch of us were
screaming about this clearly that wasn't
enough yep so what would you tell the
people of 30 years ago how you going to
fix this that is an extremely difficult
thought problem and in fact I fear that
the answer is is short of by the way I'm
from the future I know you're not going
to believe that but if you can get over
that one thing if I can establish that
one thing for you then I've got a
message about what's about to happen and
what you have to do to prevent it and
why it matters right that you could do
but if there's no way to convey hey
actually I've seen where this goes and
it's not good right so you need Marty
telling doc that he fell off the toilet
to figure out the flux capacitor but
short of that we're kind of screwed I
think so because I know you know
actually it's funny Heather and I have a
little uh just sort of private thought
experiment you know because we knew each
other in high school I'm often saying to
her don't you wish that we could uh just
tell our high school selves about the
present and what would they say right
and the answer is it's not plausible
yeah the idea that we would get here is
is unimaginable and I think people I
don't want to say would rightly reject
re the message because it would sound
too Preposterous but of course it would
I mean we're fighting about whether men
can become women whether you know
pedophilia is a sexual orientation that
you can do nothing about and we should
be tolerant of whether 2 plus 2 really
equals four I mean literally there is
nothing left that we can agree on
nothing so okay so short of being able
to prove that you were from the future
is there anything in retrospect that we
could have done again that's the thing
that I still seem to be hung up on is
this all inevitable that the system was
going to collapse the algorithms were
going to Grapple hold of us the the uh
the rent Seekers as you're talking about
in the elite like all of it was
inevitably going to get us to this
civilizational moment well there are a
couple things that go into it which were
probably necessary ingredients and so
maybe if you could prevent one of them
you'd you'd be somewhere better and the
two that come to mind most
directly
um I think there was a terrible misstep
with
atheism and what it did was it unhooked
a set of
protections some of which really weren't
no longer necessary many of which were
still essential but for reasons that
were not literally explained in the
documents in question and I know because
for a while I was pretty close to the
only evolutionary biologist trying to
bridge this Gap and speaking to
religious people and saying look my
colleagues are telling you you're sick
with a mind virus I know that's not
right um doesn't mean that what you
think took place literally happened and
we have to have that conversation what
if what you believe is important but not
literal right getting there from an
evolutionary perspective if we could
have done that earlier and not
temporarily flirted with the idea that
you know simple atheism was something
somehow a sophisticated way of
navigating through life then
maybe um we could
have maybe those people who had
long-standing Traditions that contained
wisdom uh that might have prevented this
would have had more power when it
mattered I really think um that's so you
must be pleased then in that there
doesn't seem to be much of an atheist
movement left in America I don't know if
please is the right word but it does you
know I think that the Sam Harris Jordan
Peterson debates sort of put an end to
that movement in America as they should
have but I'm not thrilled with what I'm
seeing replace it and I think there's a
you know let's put it this way if we
take your question about what could we
have said to the people of 1995 to get
them to save us from the world of
um the the coming Calamity that is going
to happen if we just simply embrace the
religious doctrines philosophies and
values of the past and hope that we can
now ride out the storm that's one we
could stop now by having a conversation
that says look it was wrong to dispense
with these compendiums of wisdom that
we've been handed in all of these
Traditions but those compendiums of
wisdom were built by natural selection
in an environment we no longer live in
and so
we are we are stuck in a terrible
problem which is you can't embrace the
solutions of the past to get out of the
problems of the present and you can't
abandon the solutions of the past
because they're outdated because you'll
end up abandoning all sorts of stuff
that matters in ways you don't know
about so that is I I don't want to candy
coat it yeah there's no simple solution
to that that doesn't involve um
repeatedly injuring ourselves as a
civilization as we discover which
fraction of those Traditions is still
relevant which fraction has become uh
toxic and inappropriate what it should
be replaced with that's a very long-term
puzzle that you can only solve if you're
careful about it there's no there's no
solution you can deliver in the present
and say Here's the subset of those
Traditions that's still relevant here's
the part that needs to be replaced
here's what it needs to be replaced with
that's an evolutionary process that's
going to do it what does that tell you
about the evolutionary process of the
forces that have led us here on the
negative side so if the force is on the
positive side and the ideas of of
Classical liberalism let's say and the
things that have been good for the 250
the last 250 years if those are pretty
good but clearly faltering what does it
tell you about the bad ideas that
somehow got into the
system there are a couple of
Concepts maybe I'll step back one second
what we teach people even before the
academy went complet completely insane
the set of things that we would teach
somebody on the way to graduating from
college
was um pretty arbitrary it was not the
set of things that you would really want
to have on board in order to live a a
life in which you were empowered to do
meaningful things it was just sort of
some set of things that people had
taught in the past and seemed like they
were still useful are you saying lesbian
bad Mitten 2011 is isn't uh no I mean
even even really almost everything you
know we don't teach the right geology
frankly in order to understand what kind
of a planet you live on the biology we
teach is not focused on the things that
actually allow you to figure out how to
evaluate claims about a medication or a
food or we just we we are teaching a an
arbitrary curriculum and it's now gotten
and it's turned into a toxic curriculum
but arbitrary wasn't very good and so
one of the things that I would do you
think that was arbitrary or do you think
that was by Design I mean when when all
the liberal arts colleges started
teaching all of this nonsense instead of
teaching I don't know say either better
at stem subjects or or financial
literacy let's say which nobody learned
in high school and then they get to
college and then they don't even teach
it do you think is that arbitrary or is
that intentional the last chapter
clearly involves a whole hell of a lot
of sabotage and frankly you know you
know the folks who um invented
postmodernism were pretty
straightforward about the fact that they
were interested in sabotage so shouldn't
surprise us but I mean even before that
um we were dealing with a chaotic
collection of ideas that weren't to get
we we we left a lot of value on the
table for no good reason and so one
thing I would
do is I would look at certain Concepts
that are just dis proportionately
important you know I didn't learn about
chesterton's fence until I don't know
2016 maybe even later right chesterton's
fence is an incredibly important
principle the precautionary principle is
incredibly important the relevance that
these things have to the battle between
and I don't even want to say battle the
tension between conservatism and
progressivism which is a natural
attention I think if you kill either of
those things off you end up in one
disaster or another so understanding
that um just because you don't know why
some thing that we do is there it
doesn't mean it's actually pointless and
you damn well better keep track of what
happens if you decide something like the
rules of interaction between the Sexes
if you think oh that's just you know
that's it's prudishness it's oppressive
it's you know whatever Force you want to
attribute it to and we're we're wiser
than that we know we're you know we're
just primates and let's just get over it
and stop pretending sex is something
other than it is okay you know there's
not that there's no truth in that there
is some truth in it but when you get rid
of all those rules you invite a whole
lot of chaos that you didn't anticipate
and it is incumbent on you at least to
track the consequences of the change and
see how they match with what you thought
was going to happen if we had done that
right if we were comparing the world of
2023 with the world of
1960 we could say oh there are some
things that are quite a bit better then
there are a whole bunch of things that
are a whole lot worse and we could start
looking at cause and effect and say
actually we could get the best of both
of those worlds without paying the huge
price we do by you know drawing a line
here but is the problem is the inherent
problem with that is that that's just
not how human organize or or actually
respond to things so for example you
could say like gay marriage to me was a
completely just obviously a completely
just mission in that it was a quality
for people to live the way they wish
there probably should have been a
discussion around it well going okay
well what's going to come after this
then and now this radical trans thing
which has nothing to do with equality
and now is an assault on science and
biology and blah blah that there should
have you're basically asking for well
can there be like a postmortem on the
good thing so we don't let in the bad
things but it's almost just not how
humans operate right we just look then
for the next thing and that I guess is
the problem you're right this is exactly
how we do things I want to show I can't
want to show no you're you're right on
target um but notice notice this we
Embrace stuff because we see some
problem that's ging to us and we want to
solve it right that's the progressive
Instinct and so we tear apart some rule
that seems Antiquated to us and we
notice that you know we've liberated
ourselves in some way and then 20 years
later 30 years later we discover holy
crap we liberated ourselves in this way
and then we constrained ourselves in
some other way and we have to do a net
analysis and that the Carnage is
tremendous if you did that if you did it
one thing at a time it would be bad
enough right the the needless losses of
doing it that way would be intolerable
in my opinion but when you do it on
every we're doing it this way now
instead of occasionally kind of moving
up the ladder or something we are
revolutionizing our
civilization each decade which means you
don't get time to even figure out what
the consequences of the last change you
made are before you're somehow on to
some next Monumental change there is no
I mean anybody who has gotten good at
let's say making a car
run knows you can't do this right if you
have a problem with a car it's not
running right you change one thing at a
time and you figure out which thing
causes it suddenly to run now you know
what the problem is you know what to do
if you say well you know the car doesn't
run it could be the starter it could be
the alternator it could be the battery
it could be the wiring harnesses and you
change them all and it still doesn't run
you don't know that you didn't change
the thing that was broken and introduce
another thing that wasn't working and
that it's now not running for a whole
new reason right you can't do it that
way so one of the lessons here is the
Rebellion into conservatism is largely
right because we've done a lot of
foolish things and we've done it too
fast and too many of them but it cannot
be allowed to silence the progressive
Instinct because the way we got here is
through
progressivism what would be left that
that the progressive Instinct should be
looking at then right uh you know
interesting I would say you know I've
like everyone else I have seen
um a tremendous amount of evidence
suggesting that the story that we've
been given on climate is not a true
story doesn't mean that there's no
problem although that's within the realm
of possibility
but that fact I Veer more towards that
at this point because I think we've been
fed so much nonsense on so much that
it's just not if I'm looking at my
hierarchy of things I'm voting for and
thinking about it's not in the top 10
you just you just said the thing though
which is if you look at the kinds of
we've been fed over a wide
range of topics this looks more like
that and the problem is I guarantee you
that the story of climate that we are
being given is saturated with
okay it can't help but be saturated with
for one thing it comes from an
academic environment that we know what
would happen to you if you discovered
climate change wasn't that big a deal
and you tried to publish it we know what
would happen to you so that tells you
you can't look at the stuff that's
coming out of that discipline and say
well you know the science is pretty
clear because you didn't see any science
that went in the other direction right
that's one thing um but the problem
is the fact that somebody loaded that
story with does not tell you
what the Baseline would look like if you
took the away right I know I
was promised um that kilamanjaro would
be fle free of glaciers I know that I
was told Glacier National Park wouldn't
have them I know I was told told there'd
be an ice free Arctic and I know none
none of these things have happened and
by the way before that we were told
about global cooling absolutely and I
remember that I remember that well
so one doesn't want to miss a signal
that something important is happening
and one doesn't want to assume that
because some academic environment
especially one like the uh the study of
climate which is so thoroughly based on
models now I've been saying forever
models are not a test of anything they
can't be yeah the best they can do is
they can generate hypotheses that you
then need to test and we are using them
as if they were a test of something and
we're panicking ourselves and we are
threatening to upend our civilization um
over ideas that are probably just false
but you asked me what what we would keep
if if uh we were uh interested in not
just simply sidelining progressivism the
top one on my list would be um
environmental concerns that are about
stewardship of a planet which I feel we
are morally required not to degrade we
have an obligation to give the Next
Generation uh and on into the future a
planet that is equivalent of the one
that we that we were given by the way I
think that's a message that most
conservatives hear I mean the word
conserve is in there and conserving the
environment is part of that I I think
there's a twofold problem now one is
thei the sort of river of that
you just described and then the second
one is they become so skeptical of
government the idea that even if they
believed that the river of
wasn't 100 feet of that they'd
still say well the government can't do
anything and I'm extremely sympathetic
sympathetic to that argument me too I
mean the fact is um the government is
not on our side it's in the hands of
people I don't know what they're
thinking it looks to me like they're
destroying destroying a planet that they
need to live on also but whatever it is
that they're thinking they are not wise
people and I do not want to see them
empowered with regulatory capacity but
it doesn't mean that if we manage to
make it through this bottleneck that we
are facing that the degradation of the
planet is not a top priority it really
needs to be and this is hard to
convey um if you have a cursory
relationship ship with the natural world
if you like it you visit it and it's an
aesthetic uh joy to you but you do not
let's say return to the places that you
went as a younger person and note the
radical decrease in certain species if
you don't have that kind of longitudinal
sense of what's taking place then you
may not realize how rapidly we are
degrading the place and it's not 100%
we've done some you know when I was a
kid I never saw a bald eagle right I see
them all the time now I've seen them on
you know I've seen them in the last two
days here in Florida I see them at home
in the Pacific Northwest all the time We
rescued that animal from the brink of
Extinction and you could say the same
thing about sea otters you could say it
about uh elephant seals there's no
shortage of creatures that we've
actually Condors you know I've actually
seen them in the wild this is incredible
that we were able to do that but each of
those cases are are things that we set
about conserving intentionally and it
was not a small effort and the number of
cases that I could describe to you just
from my own experience of creatures that
I remember well that I haven't seen in a
very long time that's a longer list and
it says something about the rate at
which these environments are actually
coming
apart how worried are you that people's
brains will have so been blown apart by
Tik Tock and and algorithms and gender
confusion and neoism and the list goes
on and on that even if you sat here and
gave me the the one sheet here are the
solutions we checked them did everything
you could that there is not enough brain
power left that that the next generation
is just so blown apart in so many
different ways that there just won't be
enough to fix this that people don't
understand what freedom is that they can
watch mobs Rampage through their cities
and think the bad guys are good guys
like that everything is so upside down
that the Cavalry just ain't
coming well I
think unfortunately there's there's more
to that than than I would like but I
also you know in the Heyday of what was
called the
IDW we all stood on stages and watched
hundreds or thousands of people cheer
for rational discussion
like they were you know looking at the
Beatles it was crazy that they were so
enthusiastic and I don't think that they
were there for the nuances of
epistemology I think they were there
because they were cheering on rational
people who cared and were willing to
discuss the finer points of What
mattered so I think we need to separate
out the question
of are people going to understand the
nuances of climate well enough to be
able to spot rational policy no but our
system was designed for them not to have
to the problem is really the capture of
the system which means that it's not in
the hands of people who actually
represent the public it's in the hands
of people who represent um at the very
you know moneyed interests is probably
an Antiquated way of thinking about it
but rent seeking Elites who have hoarded
power for themselves for obvious
reasons if people heard folks who really
represented their interests and were
interested in doing the heavy lifting of
figuring out what's true even when it's
counterintuitive and doing the right
thing they would be enthusiastic for it
because frankly I think everyone is
panicked over the fact that there seem
to be no
adults I'm guessing you're a bit of at
least a bit of a Sci-Fi guy yeah you you
must be so I constantly am bringing up
basically every Philip K dick book and
the Matrix and the you know Terminator
and skynet's going to turn on it sort of
feels to me that we're just we're like
right before that scene in the movie
right now we except the what's different
about us now is that we all know the
books and we all know the you know in
all those movies and an iroot and
everything's the robots become scti and
all these things they they sort of have
never really thought about it beforehand
for some reason or there's a little bit
of it in some Asimov books but it's like
all of us we've been warned about all
these things forever and it seems to me
we're right at the moment where AI kind
of won't need us we'll be the problem in
the system and instead of the solution
to the system and all
that but I don't see a good way around
it well forgive me I don't remember what
what we talked about in London well
enough to know if I said this to you but
we are simultaneously facing the Battle
of it's not even our lives it's clearly
the battle for the future whether or not
we're going to have one in some
meaningful sense it is that scene in the
movie and it is confusing because it
isn't even one movie it seems to be all
of them simultaneously right um
and we are
facing you know it's not
aliens AI is involved in some sense you
know I mean I'm even talking in the pre
chat gbt days the algorithms the fact
that they were trying to accomplish
something that was counterproductive
from the point of view of humanity is
clearly involved so anyway it is that
moment um and there are a couple
of there are a couple of odd facts one
yeah we all read the books or saw the
movies that's not the same thing but we
still seem to careen towards it right we
seem to careen towards it because that's
not we we think that we are synonymous
with our conscious Minds that's the
thing that read the books and saw the
movies that's not the thing that acts
right the conscious mind has a limited
role to play and it's the part of the
mind that plays tennis that needs to
understand the lessons of those books
and movies and start acting and it can't
because it hasn't been through the the
training course right the equivalent of
you know what we do for Special Forces
where you know how to keep your fear in
check at the point that you're staring
at a ferociously powerful enemy that
presumably has access to every email you
ever wrote right so people need to steal
themselves and then they need to figure
out who they are in those movies right
and
it's it I think they will feel better
when they do right because on the one
hand yes they will end up calling
attention to themselves in the eyes of
whatever it is that we're up against on
the other hand they will not be
paralyzed by fear and so anyway I I I
think people to convert over into an
action uh do you think it's possible
that when we pulled that curtain back
that it actually is just the old washed
up Wizard and not the old Powerful Oz CU
that's basically what you're saying that
that what people are afraid of is if
they saw what was on the other side we'd
be so cowed or or or we're imagining
something that's so scary that we'll
never pull it back on the other hand
maybe the whole lesson was that when you
pull it back there's not much there
wouldn't that be nice well I think think
it's going to be a mixture of things
because let's take uh and I know people
are sick of talking about Co nobody more
than me but I think we need to talk
about it because the fact that you
showed up here in a mask is still so
frankly
disturbing yeah fou few but ex the uh
the the lessons of Co are
profound the most important lesson of Co
is that
outgunned as we were not understanding
what this virus was what the treatments
that they wanted us to take or the
preventive measures they wanted us to
take were what the drugs that they
seemed hellbent on preventing us from
having access to where without
understanding the game we out foxed them
and their narrative collapsed people are
now aware the shots were very dangerous
there were drugs that worked that they
were not allowed to access there were
contributing factors like vitamin D that
were important that people who claimed
to be obsessed about their safety never
bothered to tell them about um the virus
didn't come from bats in nature it came
through a route that could easily have
been prevented by wiser people
so how did people get wise to this in
light of the fact that this thing owns
every major broadcast network every
newspaper every Medical School uh every
University
well I don't know it happened on
podcasts that shouldn't have been
possible and what that does suggest is
that there's a good bit of um the
shriveled old men behind the curtain
right that as powerful as this force was
it wasn't especially smart it did not
especially understand us it is now I
swear looking for a rematch yeah if you
look at what it's doing in the World
Health
Organization what it just did with the
FCC see um what it's doing in Colorado
with a new program to infect bats with
dangerous human pathogens I it looks
like it's it wants a rematch on every
front
so it wants new rules that will prevent
us from doing that next time we need
it's leveling up we now need to level up
but were we to level up here's the good
news that I know you're asking me to
tell you about which
is um forgive me for saying it this way
Goliath up okay Goliath took
every intelligent courageous person with
integrity and shoved them all onto our
team
simultaneously so we don't have the
technology we don't have any of the
materials that one would want to fight
this battle but we have absolutely every
player that you would want
so we out foxed them one
we need to level up we cannot assume
that what we did last time is going to
work in the same form it will not
because Goliath is very stupid when he
sees something new but he learns and
he's learning so we need to go after him
with an improved game plan um and if we
do my sense is actually we can stay
ahead of them you know it's interesting
because you said one of the big problems
is how atheism sort of crept in over the
last 30 years or whatever it is and then
the way you just described that was
actually kind of biblical because you're
talking about David verse Goliath and I
wonder if you think as a biologist who
is largely a secular person you're
Jewish I think Heather's Catholic or is
Heather Christian or uh her father was
Catholic father was Catholic um I only
mention that because I think that
something weird is going on with a
little bit of the code as it relates to
the Jews as I'm seeing a whole bunch of
Jews kind of more into religion over the
last two months and into the traditions
and some of that stuff that you were
asking people not to throw away before
yeah um let's just put it this way this
is not new with me I freely use these
metaphors because I think they're
fundamentally important and
interestingly you heard me say Goliath I
didn't say David because there's a
literal version of this story that
probably did happen David was not the
killer of Goliath Goliath was probably a
pituitary tumor giant um and he was
killed by a guy named elhanan and those
who wrote the Bible composited
characters because David needed an
origin story um but anyway the the point
is I don't expect anybody else to do
this I think it's cool if you can and
think it's worthwhile but you know I
don't have to resort to anything um
Supernatural in order to maintain
contact with um those biblical stories
and what it is that they're trying to
tell us they do need an update Goliath
is not an individual anymore clearly
David or elh Hanan is not going to be an
individual either right it's going to
take more than a slingshot because this
thing has a lot of firewalls right but
again the real lesson of Co is that
um when we figure when we got our
bearings we ended up remarkably powerful
relative to this force that had us so
thoroughly outgun well that that's why I
mentioned the religious part because I'm
starting to think it's that survival is
baked into the code too that right like
the oppression is baked into into the
code and then the survival part is is
then always baked into the code too yes
and then there's one other element uh oh
um no it's a good one I think um I I
honestly believe that the thing I'm
calling Goliath the force that opposes
meaningful
change does not understand and therefore
does not anticipate the action of people
who have courage and integrity and
insight it can't fathom them because
it's not built of that kind of stuff and
so it keeps misjudging what we'll do
what will cause us to back down and as
long as it keeps misjudging that then we
have a lot of room to maneuver it's
interesting because that's why I talk
about Elon as much as I do on the show
because I don't I think if you would
have said to Elon 10 years ago you'd own
Twitter you'd be in this free speech
fight you'd have you know the ADL
calling you an anti-semite like the list
of craziness that everyone now knows I
think he'd say what are you talking
about that's completely insane I'm
trying to get us to Mars I'm building
this cool car blah blah blah but he I
think is sort of the avatar for what
you're talking about there the the brave
person that like doesn't know exactly
what they're going towards something
like that but then he's like I better
buy this freaking Twitter thing because
I see all the danger much like a
professor that's like oh I'm going to be
hunted off campus because I'm going to
not bow and the rest of it all right
well I'm going to take a risk because I
think frankly time is
short um I think you're right about Elon
I don't know for sure that you are but I
think you're right about what he's
trying to do and how he ended up there
and how it would surprise
him I had a meeting with him I flew to
San Francisco and I had a meeting with
him and he said it had been a very good
meeting and he wanted to meet
again a series of events unfolded over
the course of the next 20 4 hours um my
Twitter account got commandeered maybe
that was organic maybe it wasn't I don't
think I I know Elon had nothing to do
with it but anyway I reached out to him
and uh tried to alert him to this
because I was concerned that he and I
had private Communications and he didn't
want you know I don't think there was
anything compromising in them but he
didn't want them in the world and he
needed to know that this was there um
and he ended up uh blocking me after
having this meeting and I remain blocked
now the reason I raise it is
because there's a defect in all of those
players that I mentioned who have all
been shoved onto the same team right
they have some incredible strengths and
I have to tell you um there's been a lot
of
uh pain inflicted on us for standing up
but the camaraderie the discovery of
people who were up to the challenge the
their coming together as a coalition has
been extremely rewarding and dwarfs any
suffering that might have come along
with this yeah it sounds kind of corny
but I mean that those three days or
whatever it was we had at ARC to see
everybody together again and all be like
we're still alive we're still here it's
powerful yeah um the problem is that all
of those people who have the
characteristics that I listed that are
courageous that are insightful and that
have in Integrity they
tend they have a lot of Lone wolfess in
them which means that they have a defect
they're terrible at
confederating and my concern is I'm
watching Elon now maybe Elon isn't what
he appears to be but to my way of
thinking he probably is I think he's got
a um I think he's got a desire to save
the planet it it happens to be a moment
at which saving the planet is not a
ridiculous thing to be focused on um
right and he happens to be kind of the
guy that can do it you know if anybody's
got you money he does and that's
exactly what you would want and he also
you know is very insightful I see him as
very strategically clever but I don't
think he's any good at confederating
either and my little story where you
know he blocked me it's like
look hey Elon there aren't that many
people out here trying to advance the
ball who have something
um meaningful to contribute to the team
we have to stop tripping over each other
so so maybe I feel like I'm missing like
a tiny piece of the story which is what
do you think he blocked you over not to
totally sidestep us here but I also can
get access to him probably so it's like
well let's let's put it this way um what
happened was so I believe that dark
horse that Heather and and I have faced
a uh a whole bunch of ression that um
has not yet shown up anywhere the
Twitter files that's the podcast that
you guys do right that's that's our
podcast and there's a reason that we
still you know we are demonetized to
this day YouTube demonetized us I
believe they were going to throw us off
uh Joe Rogan held an emergency podcast
and you know YouTube hasn't messed with
us since but they didn't
been a lot and we know actually that
that decision happened in the sea suite
at Google mhm
so whatever is going on there was a lot
of direct interference with us why
because a lot of what happened over
covid um went through Darkhorse and the
reason you know was Heather and I are
both PhD biologists who what we were
doing before
frankly May 23rd of 2017 shortly
thereafter I showed up on your podcast
first uh major venue I was
on um what we were doing before that
date was we were taking complex
phenomena and making them simple and
intuitive so students could learn and
use these ideas when we started to do
that with covid when we started to take
it out of the realm of here's a bunch of
stuff you can't understand and leave it
to the virologists and the
epidemiologists and the public health
authorities and the answer was no
actually you can understand it and some
of what you're being told isn't right
right when we started to do that and
then we started to interact with people
like Robert Malone and Peter Mulla um
Pier Corey and then those people went on
to affect a huge audience right largely
on Joe Rogan's
program that changed the narrative and
so I
think something has meddled with us in a
particular in a unique way because
frankly there weren't that many people
who could Bridge the scientific to sure
but connect connect that to Elon
blocking you because on one hand I think
you're saying he's the good guy in this
story so I think there's one missing
he's here's the connection yeah um
when I contacted Elon after my account
was
commandeered I was trying to point him
to things about my account that does not
behave normally and incidentally in the
conversation that I had with I was
unfollowed from you right before that
remember I contacted you and texted you
and said he you were one of the first
like four people I ever followed on
there so that's interesting it could
mean something I I'm not sure I'm not
sure what it means but I was trying to
convey something to him which is I think
when you you know as you know because
you talked to Elon about the things he
was discovering inside of the crime
scene that he bought yeah and one of the
things that he discovered was that there
were lots of mechanisms that caused
things to be deboosted that weren't
labeled as such and so he kept finding
more and more levels and I was trying to
convey to him look I think you will find
something special when you figure out
what happened to us now maybe that's
wrong but I wasn't talking to him
privately about this for personal
selfish reasons though I would love the
problem to have been solved for those
reasons I was telling him that because I
believe that in his quest to make
Twitter into the new Public Square in
which
ah right that he would discover those
things at the point he chased this down
so he then blocked me saying Stop
spamming me which was a very strange
thing for him to say in light of the
conversation that he and I had
had a lot there lot there I'd be happy
to talk to him about that maybe you'll
we send him his clip or I'll I'll
message him but but let's put it this
way let's say that let's say that I've
got it all but is your but is your fear
it's not that you spamming him like
blowing up his feet what you're really
saying in essence is that you were a
little too ahead of something in the
game at which the speed is played that
he may not want to be involved in that
just yet something like that well I that
that's possible what I you know if I
take everything at face value okay I was
trying to tell him something about the
machine that he bought and I'm taking
him at his word as to why he bought it
what what he wanted to accomplish I was
trying to help him in that that and it
involved things that I can see in my
account and you know he told me that you
know one of the things that was true
before he bought Twitter he had the most
engaged with account and that he could
feel that the way the account worked was
unnatural so I'm reporting something
that he had experienced personally in
his own
life
the it is possible that he took my
messages to him as my thinking that he
was like customer service or something M
and that that him which I would get but
my my point is really this no matter
what happened there the idea that people
who are interested in you know who are
aware for example of the importance of
even a single social media platform
functioning in a free and open way with
respect to ideas right on on Darkhorse
we have the phrase zero is a special
number what that means is if you can
turn a single social media platform a
single newspaper or a single University
so that it functions towards its stated
goal you actually stand a chance of
fixing the system because if there's one
social media platform on which you're
treated like an adult and you can
exchange ideas freely and discuss them
back and forth nobody's going to want to
be on the ones in which you're treated
like a child right so so in essence
that's why he's hated the way he is at
the moment or why the system reacts so
that's separate then whatever may or may
not have happened with you guys it's why
he's in the bullseye but I guess the
point is if we are talking about the
fact that what he is doing stands to
change the whole system for deep game
theoretic reasons that as far as I know
we're the only people talking about then
it doesn't make sense for us to be
tripping over each other right even even
if I misread the signals that were going
on in my discussion with him then the
answer is okay so you said hey stop
spamming me message
received it didn't need to become a you
know this this was a block actually
before Elon even started talking about
the fact that blocks were no good so
without making it so specifically about
you guys cuz since we we just don't know
the answer that I get it you don't know
either and I will ask him about this and
I'll send him this clip like why not
let's see what happens hopefully 'll get
blocked I don't think I will but but you
never but who knows but do you think
there's a there's a probably a
biological answer for that too in terms
of how we all operate meaning that he
now he's in a complex system now the
system's attacking him he's getting some
sort of like signal boost from other
good forces within the system but he can
only be boosted so far because he can
only do so much at once so you sometimes
want to put blinders on for some of the
other stuff well this is what I was
saying about the lone
wolfess for all of us who got into some
interesting position in this battle
because we were independent enough of
the institutions that we were part of
that when they went crazy we refused
something like
that the there probably is a built-in
circuit that says you know don't
affiliate with things that are too
complex CU you don't know what's buried
in there and what it means is that you
know how do you create the pack of Lone
wolves right A Lone Wolf is the opposite
of a pack at the point that the lone
wolves are the only on standing and they
need to become a pack the answer is
they've got to Now resort to a skill set
that they pretty obviously don't have
right so they have to bootstrap it and I
guess that's what I'm saying is this is
the moment at which all of us who have
found ourselves um ejected and singled
out and remained standing have to figure
out how to do the thing that we don't
know how to do and
um it's not surprising that that is
going to involve a lot of missteps and
it's going to involve um practicing and
it is going to involve us I mean there
are people who do this very naturally
they just right are they're not here
bring every right right right bring
everybody into the fold and figure out
some of I think I was trying maybe a
little more than some of us to do some
of that obviously it didn't it didn't
fully work and I don't mean that as a
pat on my back like we all have our
strengths and weaknesses and and
whatever but do do you think it's
possible that this is what you're asking
for sort of at the public layer of
people is exactly what everyone needs at
the private layer of people meaning what
you just said to me is what every single
person actually needs not just the crazy
hundred of us who are yapping on you
know online well two things one I I do
think you deserve a pat on the back you
were doing unique things um you know
when you used to uh take various ones of
us up on stage with you for some hybrid
between comedy and political discussion
right that was actually that was that
was Bridge Crossing stuff and it was it
was really cool I think about it a lot I
learned a lot in in those few
interactions the ones with you actually
in some ways were the most fun because
you really considered yourself a man of
the left at the time and were very
proudly saying it and I was the leave
the left guy and my audience as you
would always point out you'd always say
to me Dave your audience is more
conservative than you so here we have
tried and true conservatives coming to
see me certainly not a traditional
conservative bringing on you a lefty and
we'd get standing ovations every time I
mean it really was something it was
great so I guess I'll Pat myself on the
back for that I think you should but I
also think um there are many this this
is now me uh pretending to be older than
I am and trying to uh pass on some
wisdom there are many things in life
that you don't understand how long the
trajectory actually is like healing you
know uh I had an ACL injury um tear and
it was repaired and there was definitely
a one-year healing but there was also a
5-year healing and a 10-year healing
process and you know I literally have to
think carefully to remember which leg it
was at this point you know I have a torn
ACL right now no I have no ACL it tore
about 5 years ago I never did anything
and now it's gone all together and yet
I'm playing basketball tonight because
of PRP and three
braces I wrap it I got the sleeve and
the metal thing I mean it's like I'm
like a Transformer out there well I have
it on the inside and it's now I've now
forgot now you forgot it's a beautiful
thing right but the point is there were
you know if you checked in along a
10-year trajectory you would find that
actually there was important stuff in
that process going on the whole time so
what you were doing and what we were all
doing you know um
IDW doesn't exist but it was a very
important stage in something that I
think doesn't have a name at the moment
um what you were
doing was somehow a a prototype of what
you are doing and uh I think I think
there's meaningful progress if you look
across that whole Arc and um anyway uh I
appreciate it and I think it's important
stuff so keep it up I should probably
end right there but I'm but I'm not
going to that would be an interesting
ending to this are you it's interesting
because on some hand you strike me
suddenly as you're very like you seem
more of a realist than ever at the
moment or something like I can't quite
tell if
you're if you're sort of not depressed
if you're dejected about the direction
or I sense also a determination in you
that like but we will beat this thing um
couple things I think
um what
happened when you and I met we
met as I was dragged center stage in the
woke Revolution or fighting the woke
Revolution fighting against
it that was not my first
rodeo which I think probably had a lot
to do
with why I was successful in
that that was chapters ago right we're
now on to the
postco
chapter I cannot emphasize enough how
important each of these major events is
in building a model of what what these
fights are about what tools are useful
in uh conducting yourself during them
what the enemy is like and you know in
these cases the enemy is you know there
are there are
overlaps um
but I I think I
[Music]
am I've now seen enough that I know this
doesn't get better if we don't fix it
I'm deeply embedded
in the complex systems aspect of this
enough to
know
that I'm 54 I have two kids
if we don't fix
this then you know maybe my kids find a
way to live out their lives in some
decent form maybe
they find mates and produce Offspring
and they find some way to protect those
Offspring for their lives but it's not
a it's not a good story if we don't fix
it and so I guess I have
just
the thing spends a lot of time trying to
Spook us about what's going to happen if
we stand up to it and I'm not sure that
it's bluffing
but what else is there right well that's
what it is I suppose so when you look
behind the curtain it might be the all
Powerful Oz it might be a shriveled up
old you know used car salesman might be
something in between either way you got
to give it your best go I guess is the
point right like that would be the point
of humanity yeah and like what's the
choice so you find out you're wrong okay
you did everything you could that's
still pretty decent I mean it goes back
to your point about those those novels
and and those movies because we all
understand so deeply who we're rooting
for it's not ambiguous we know who we're
rooting for we know what we want them to
do and then when we find ourselves in
the position where it's us having to
make those choices the point is well you
know what you're supposed to do cuz you
saw the movie right
right if Neo had put the thing back in
his head then you would be like all
right I'm not so into this that's why
they gave us Cipher right right Cipher
is the cautionary tale and so at some
level point you know it's not going to
be the Hollywood version it's not going
to look like Neo it's not going to
involve the fancy battle where you're
dodging the bullets and the slow-mo and
all that you know that's not what it is
but to the extent that the Matrix is
Plato's Cave Revisited for a generation
that needed an update
mhm the point is
the what must happen is still
clear the the non- Hollywood of the
story can't dissuade you
and you know I think I guess I'm I'm
hoping that people will realize that
they're not going to
feel just totally at ease when they
confront their fears over standing up
and what happens if you do in fact they
will spend a lot of time wondering what
comes next but there is a part of them
that is not settled watching this happen
and not standing up that
will just simply realize that it doesn't
it doesn't have a lot of choice and it
doesn't want a lot of choice right
you're facing a an epic battle that
isn't even just for you know Western
Civilization we are literally talking
about the future of the human race and
whether there will be one so if that
doesn't get you
to stand up
and face the enemy irrespective of what
it is you know if the enemy is all
powerful and it's going to destroy those
of us who stand up then the point is
what that will do is it will destroy
everyone else shortly thereafter so
you're not safe saving yourself that
much you might as well face the thing
and the lesson of frankly the woke
Revolution and uh covid and much else is
that actually you might be surprised
that you end up on the winning team and
that feels pretty good so you know I
think it's just
time that is the
ending if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop screaming
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell